- Guillaume Duguay fait
sa ronde quotidienne.
Il qualifie sa deuxième saison
de pêche au crabe commun,
aussi appelé le crabe des
roches, comme étant excellente,
elle qui a débuté le 1er août.
Chaque jour, le pêcheur navigue
près des côtes et retire
des fonds marins ses 75 cages
placées à 18 mètres,
ou 60 pieds, de profondeur.
- Ça commence!
- Guillaume Duguay
ne s'étonne pas de voir
ses cages fourmiller de crabes.
Il en récolte généralement
3000 livres au quotidien, et ce,
jusqu'à la fin de la saison,
qui se termine le 26 septembre,
pour un grand total de
100 à 150 000 livres.
GUILLAUME DUGUAY,
capitaine propriétaire
- Je te dirais qu'un crabe,
c'est un peu comme un...
moi, j'appelle ça un peu
un vidangeur de mer.
Écoute, ça se promène dans
le fond, ça mange vraiment tout
ce qui va traîner dans le fond.
Fait que, ça va manger
du maquereau, ça va manger
des petits coquillages,
des étoiles de mer.
Mais, nous autres, en tant que
pêcheurs, c'est beaucoup
harengs, maquereaux.
- Il se réjouit donc de voir
la ressource intégrer l'assiette
des consommateurs québécois,
cette année, avec un projet-
pilote de promotion du crabe
commun qui implique
15 restaurants.
Ce restaurateur constate déjà
un bel enthousiasme auprès
de la population pour découvrir
ce crustacé. Il qualifie le goût
de ce tourteau comme étant
très fin et plus sucré
que le crabe des neiges.
GHISLAIN COLLIN, propriétaire,
Rest. et poissonnerie du Quai
- Nous, ce qu'on fait,
c'est qu'on le fait bouillir
dans l'eau salée comme le crabe
et le homard. Je pense
que c'est la meilleure recette
pour les fruits de mer, puis...
ça garde son goût, puis on va
le servir avec un peu de beurre
à l'ail comme le classique.
- Selon le programme
La Fourchette bleue, il s'agit
d'une belle façon pour
les amateurs de fruits de mer
du Québec de découvrir
les richesses marines
vivant chez eux, dans
le golfe du Saint-Laurent.
Le crabe commun est considéré
par Pêches et Océans Canada
comme une espèce émergente
au Québec. L'exploitation
commerciale de cette ressource
a débuté en 1988, mais ce n'est
qu'à partir de 1995 que la pêche
a pris un essor réel.
Le crabe commun demeure l'une
des proies préférées au homard.
C'est pourquoi une gestion
très prudente est justifiée pour
prévenir toute surexploitation.
Ici Guillaume Whalen,
Radio-Canada, Sainte-Madeleine-
de la Rivière-Madeleine